[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
bum
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to play anime live my name is
christian perez
associate social content producer here
at bandai namco entertainment america
today at play anime live we're going to
be covering all sorts of content
for anime because we love anime and we
know you guys love anime
so what we're gonna be covering is
season pass information dlcs
and an ama from scarlet nexus producer
keita
zuka but before we get started i'd like
to bring on the og
senpai's of play anime that's right the
ogs y'all know them
cyrus wesson and stephen akana what's up
steven hello priscilla how's it going
i'm becoming co-high on the anime team
thank you my name is steven akana i'm
senior global brand manager at bandai
namco entertainment america
uh really excited to be here i mean
normally about this time we would be in
the height of con season so
we would be meeting up with you guys at
you know our cons that we do every year
e3
anime expo san diego comic-con these are
times that we look forward to every year
on being able to not just show you guys
some of the new content that we have
have you guys try out some new playables
but also just to be able to meet with
you guys one-on-one and be able to talk
shop i mean we love anime we love games
you know that you guys do obviously so
we love to just be able to share that
with you guys
missing out on that this year for sure
but that's why we wanted to come to you
with a play anime live
which gives you a little taste of some
of the stuff that we would have done
at events so thinking about great ways
for you to find out new content
be able to win maybe some prizes uh
there's a lot of different things that
we have planned for you
um just remember that we have
pre-recorded this event
due to some restrictions of being in the
office
but uh the moderators that we have on
the stream they're live right now so
um don't sleep on the moderators make
sure you engage with them uh and
to my right i also have cyrus how's it
going on cyrus hey steven how's it going
hi everybody my name is cyrus wesson i'm
the associate social media manager
for bandai namco entertainment america
and i'm just super excited to be here to
talk to you guys about anime
you see what you gotta understand about
bandai namco and the personnel that work
here is we
all love anime and we're super excited
about all of this content
so we wanted to really make sure to
deliver the best presentation that we
can give to you
so that you can get all the information
about the new products that we have
coming out
and in addition to that we've got some
really really cool giveaways actually
so if you make sure that you're talking
to your moderators that are live in the
chat
right now you'll be able to win one of
five vip
boxes and those vip boxes have all sorts
of anime content within them
so that's just one of the many ways that
you can win something from this stream
and
i think krisha has another way that you
can win something
pretty cool so krisha what can they do
for north america viewers on both the
twitch platform and facebook gaming
25 of you will be able to win a vip
box that's anime themed that's right 25
of you
will be able to win this box as well the
details of that is in the description
below also for those of you who are
watching on the twitch platform
you connect your bandai namco
entertainment america account
with your twitch account you will get a
free copy of naruto's shinobi striker
for free on steam that's right all of
this is free
and all you have to do is go to the
description below in our about section
hit that link to learn more about both
the vip box
and naruto shinobi striker for free on
steam
after this stream you're actually going
to get an email with all that detail
if you already selected for the box and
you're going to get your code at the end
so let's hit this content let's get this
show rolling
and let's jump right into our first
trailer
[Music]
baby you have room for improvement
was that me hatsume trailer in english
yo so
back in may we actually updated uh my
hero 1's justice 2 with english vo for
all the characters
plus all the dlc that's going to be
coming out for season passes
all of them are going to be in english
so everything from now on from my hero
ones justice 2 is going to be in english
for you guys really really excited it's
actually a big
big undertaking for us to be able to
roll that out but um
something that you know fans really
wanted and it's something that we feel
like is going to be something that you
guys really enjoy
let us know in the comments what you
think about it uh but we have a lot of
content that's going to be coming up
really soon for my hero ones justice 2.
so
keep a lookout for a photo mode this
photo mode is going to feature two
different ways a portrait
where you can stage different types of
poses with your characters do frames all
that type of stuff
um and there's also going to be an
action shot that you can do so
staging up you know a hero versus hero
villain versus villain
whoever you want to stage up in like
your favorite uh posed action shots
either way this photo mode's got it set
up for you guys as fans to do whatever
you want to do
um and then in addition to that we also
have some new dlc that's going to be
coming out so keep an eye out for the
villains costume pack that's going to
feature formal wear so all of them are
going to be wearing suits
it's really really cool that we have all
this new content coming out
keep an eye out on our social channels
bandai namco us
for the exact date when those content
pieces are going to come out so
cyrus i know that when codevain released
their photo mode
you were stuck in there for like weeks
so what do you think about this my hero
ones just this two photo mode like i
know
you must be freaking out look steven all
i'm gonna say is
click click and snap snap i'm going to
be making
so many images in that photo mode that's
awesome you're telling me that i can
take
a new fight scene with shigeraki and
toga
and pit them together against one
another or do my dream bakugou
versus midoriya fight that's amazing
your fan fiction is becoming reality my
friend
i can't wait i can't wait and you
shouldn't wait either
i mean you're going to have to until it
comes out but once it does
super excited to see what you guys come
up with krisha what are you excited
for honestly for this photo mode i'm
about to get togahumiko's
pink suit because that suit is hella
fire y'all
i need it i need a cosplay is that it's
gonna happen real real
soon you guys check it out pink suit
cosplay but you guys that was a lot of
content and that was a lot of updates
but i'm pretty sure there's way more so
let's hit that next trailer
i'm taking that hidden treasure and
nobody can stop me
to become king of the pirates you'll
need to be as strong as me
i'll be even stronger i'll do whatever
it takes
[Music]
[Music]
need more one piece in your life don't
be like this guy
one piece treasure cruise the officially
licensed epic anime pass rpg based on
one piece for mobile devices
experience the entire story from romance
down to the land of wano
thousands of characters including dozens
of everyone's favorite luffy
we've got lupu with this flag luffy with
zoro snake man luffy luffy with nice
[Music]
now how much would you pay for an
incredible game like this twenty
thousand dollars
we won't charge you that we won't even
charge you sixty dollars we're gonna
give you this game absolutely free
with optional enough purchases that way
there's more
download now and enjoy three premium
character recruits to start building
your crew now
download now for ios and android one
more time that's wonky treasure cruise
for ios and android
download now wow
that was a dope trailer one piece
treasure cruise
has been out for like five years you
guys why haven't you picked it up yet
it's on ios it's on android and you can
play it on the go
and for somebody like me i don't really
have time to watch
the 900 episodes of one piece that there
are i already did that for naruto i
don't really have time to do it for one
piece
but what i can do is play the one piece
story
in all of the different video games that
we have
showcasing one piece and in this one in
one piece
treasure cruise you're able to take
thousands upon thousands of characters
and put them together
in your party and experience the story
for yourself
that's so cool steven i know that
you've played one piece treasure cruise
a lot i think
why don't you tell them about it it was
a bit of a problem for me for a little
bit
but i think my twitter feed is no longer
just snail like uh
alerts that's good um you know it's it's
a really fun game and it's also
it's that type of mobile game that i
like to play like i like the card
collecting that
is done in it um but you know for me
when i think about a game that i'd want
to play to to really get
a good piece of that story the pirate
warrior series for one piece has been
awesome like pirate warriors 3
was a great way to be able to find out
the story from the beginning to
dressrosa
now with pirate warriors 4 which is
available on
playstation 4 xbox pc
and for switch that's a great way to be
able to find out all the events leading
up to
uh current events of wanokuni um plus
there's a whole bunch of different
characters that you can play as
uh we actually have a season pass for
one piece pirate warriors four and three
new characters that are going to be
releasing
let's check out that trailer that's
showcasing judge
cracker and smoothie let's check it out
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
well that trailer was fire you guys let
the moderators know what you guys think
about
judge smoothie and cracker they're out
now so you guys can pick them up
download them today now krisha we have
all this cool stuff for our fans
watching they just got to do that one
thing to get the one thing
what do they got to do for north america
viewers on twitch
if you connect your bandai namco
entertainment america account with your
twitch account
you will get a free copy of naruto to
baruto
shinobi striker for free on steam that's
right
you get a free copy of shinobi striker
on steam you'll receive an email after
this live stream
with your info on this game and
you know just a segue into naruto for a
second i have a quick little uh
confession for you guys i just started
watching naruto
and i'm actually on episode 63 and i'm
pretty obsessed with it and i'm actually
pretty sad i didn't watch it beforehand
so more about naruto for you guys season
past three
just came out this month and we have a
special trailer for you
right now let's check it out
[Music]
[Music]
huh
kakashi though
stephen had a second so
i'm not going to get in between any of
this right now because she's having her
moment with her man
but i'm also not going to get in between
y'all and these vip boxes
y'all are very important players we just
want to remind you these vip boxes they
are anime themed this time
cyrus what can our fans expect inside of
these boxes this time
steven this is an anime themed vip
box and all i'm trying to do right now
is get these
vip boxes to you guys at home so if you
are
active in the chat with your moderators
throughout this stream
or if you follow the link below and
follow the directions
you can be entered to win one of 25 vip
boxes and it's got
statues in it it's got lanyards in it
it's got steel books in it just all
anime goodness
so while you guys are doing that and
following those directions
let's watch this trailer
[Music]
big
[Music]
hey
[Music]
yo gun and battle gunpla warfare is
where it's at you guys got to check out
this game
right now it's out for ios and android
and it's celebrating its first year of
operation
right now so there's no better time for
you guys to download check out the
information for all the exclusives that
you guys are going to get
celebrating in that year anniversary but
we're all about more fun for everyone
and we want to make sure that no matter
where you guys game whether it's on your
mobile device
whether it's on your pc whether it's on
your home console that we have you guys
covered with anime games in spades
and when it comes to gundam we got you
covered for sure
so on playstation 4 definitely check out
mobile suit gundam
battle operation 2. this is a
free-to-play title so you guys
have no reason to not go pick it up
right now download it it's a great
team-based gundam game for you guys to
check out exclusively on playstation 4.
in addition on playstation 4 we also
have coming real soon
mobile suit gundam extreme versus maxi
boost on this is an
arcade perfect port of the 2 versus 2
fighting game
straight from japan arcades really
excited about this game
it has over 180 mobile suits in it like
cyrus i think even your favorite mobile
suit is in this game
steven my favorite mobile suit is in
this game and i'm so excited about it
i've been asking for this mobile suit
for years i've gone to japan
i've asked them to put it in the game
and they finally
finally finally did it that's what i'm
excited for you guys so please if you
know
what my favorite mobile suit is because
i've been on live streams in the past
and you guys are huge bandai namco fans
please let the moderators know in the
chat and maybe you'll be entered to win
one of these play anime boxes
but let me be really clear with you
about gundam maxi boost on
it is one of the most intricate esports
style gundam games
i've ever played it's honestly the most
intricate esports style game i've ever
played
you constantly have to keep so many
things
in your mind about your environment and
how
your opponents are playing how your
teammate is playing
you need to understand your mobile suits
point value
your teammate's mobile suit point value
the mobile suits that you're going up
against
where the mobile suits are on your map
there's so much that you have to keep in
mind within this game
and the best part about it i think you
mentioned it
there are over a hundred different
mobile suits for you to pick from
if you want to jump into a gundam you
can do that if you want to jump into a
gel goog you can do that
if you want to play as a zaku you can do
that
and each mobile suit has so many
different
abilities and characteristics that are
very personal to their own
so steven they don't have much time to
pre-order this game
the last day for you to pre-order is
july 29th because this game comes out on
july 30th
what are they going to get with this
pre-order steven so for y'all that are
big fans of iron bladed orphans
you guys do not want to sleep on this
pre-order because you are going to get
a free copy of uh barbados lupus rex
so having access to barbados lupus rex
is actually a really really big deal
but in addition to that you guys are
going to get some exclusive dlc for
another gundam game
so for mobile suit gundam battle
operation 2 when you guys pre-order
maxi boost on you're going to get an
exclusive operator
for battle operation 2. really really
cool deal
great opportunity for you guys to get
that extra piece of dlc to go with that
free to play game
it's free why not get it i think it's a
great deal right cyrus i think it's a
great deal
and steven where bandai namco okay
we produce games constantly for all of
these different anime titles
we've got another title that they don't
have that much time to pre-order for
so why don't we roll that next trailer
for captain tsubasa
rise of new champions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
my
[Applause]
that's right y'all captain tsubasa rise
of new champions
comes out august 28th for pc
nintendo switch and the ps4 and what i
just saw on that trailer
is that this game has multiplayer
oh it's so epic steven why are you
excited for captain tsubasa rise of new
champions
so for those of you guys who don't know
this is our first sports anime title
that we're bringing out to the west it's
a really really big moment for us
we have a lot of information to share
with you about captain subasa rising new
champions before that release on august
28th
so just be sure to follow us on our
social networks we got some handles down
below thank you post
um but you know we're always trying to
think what is
that content that's gonna make our fans
super excited
you know content's king right krisha of
course i mean here at bandai namco we
really care about the content but we
also really care about the experiences
for all of our fans that's you guys
like we mentioned we would have been
together at anime expo this would have
been the play army panel but what we
wanted to do
right now was provide you this
experience that you can do
at home check out this next trailer for
the ar experience
for scarlet nexus
[Applause]
[Music]
what you guys just saw was how to
activate this
ar experience you're going to hit this
qr code and then scan the marker
to jump right into the world of scrap
nexus later this year we're going to
roll out a ton of updates
and really awesome activities for you
guys to do in this experience
personally i'm super excited about
scarlet nexus stephen can you tell us
more about this game
yeah for sure so scarlet nexus it's a
brain punk jrpg set in a dystopian
future
where abilities are commonplace and you
take the role of
uitosumuragi and you are joining an
elite squad
of psyonix it's a really cool jrpg
that's being made by bandai namco
studios so
this has a lot of team members that
worked on tales of vasparia so
it's nice to see how a lot of these team
members have graduated
into um bigger roles and have taken on
doing what they do best delivering a
story driven narrative
that's wrapped around a um a jrpg
gaming model um and another cool fact is
that the
producer of scarlet nexus also produced
code vein so more about this producer
keita zucca
we actually asked you guys last month to
provide questions for this next segment
we're going to do an ask me anything
with azuka-san
so let's check that out
is
is
is
[Music]
hi so this is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
yes
foreign
[Music]
is
thank you stay tuned we want to thank
you guys for watching play anime live
once again this was brought to you
because we could not be together this
summer at our favorite events
mods i actually gotta check in with
y'all real quick did you
give away those boxes to our fans
watching
fans have they been giving you guys
stuff i sure hope so
stephen yeah you know i mean for us at
bandai namco it has been really hard for
us to not be able to
have those in-person connections with
our fans at events this summer
but that gives us an opportunity to
think outside of the box and how are we
going to be able to
still make those connections with you
guys digitally and that's what play
anime live is going to be for
so want to make sure that you guys have
taken a chance to go to playanime.com
forward slash live
filled out the information for your
chance to win one of these
25 vip anime themed boxes
it's a really great way to get some of
that cool bandai namco swag
without going to one of the events this
year but you want to check your email so
it's only 25 winners you guys will find
out after the stream
just keep your eyes peeled and while
you're checking those emails make sure
that you check
to see for your code for naruto to
border to shinobi striker
if you have connected your bandai namco
entertainment america account
with your twitch account you're going to
get nodder toe to border to shinobi
striker for pc via steam
for free just make sure you check those
emails okay
cyrus what do you got to say for our
fans i just have one thing to say
you guys we just gave you guys so much
anime content and so many different
anime video games
there's games that you can buy there's
games that you can download for free
there's dlc that you can get so whatever
you want
go and pick it up there is a game out
there for you here at bandai namco
we're all about play anime we love anime
that's why we do these types of things
so please go out and pick up that game
that you want
and let us know what you guys are mostly
excited about
with that said i'm cyrus wesson i'm
stephen akana
and i'm krisha perez and we'll see y'all
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you